- Bienvenido de nuevo a Entendiendo la Información
y Computación Cuántica.
Mi nombre es John Watrous y
soy el director técnico de IBM Quantum Education.
Esta es la sexta lección de la serie y es la segunda lección de
la segunda unidad, que trata sobre algoritmos cuánticos.
En la lección anterior, analizamos el modelo
de consulta de la computación, y vimos que en ese modelo, los algoritmos cuánticos pueden
ofrecer una ventaja notable
sobre los algoritmos clásicos, incluyendo una ventaja exponencial en el caso del problema de Simon.
Desafortunadamente, el modelo
de consulta no tiene ninguna relevancia
práctica directa o inmediata.
La noción de caja negra es una abstracción
muy útil, pero tenemos trabajo por
hacer si queremos aplicar
los conocimientos que hemos
obtenido del modelo de consulta a un entorno computacional más estándar donde las entradas se dan como cadenas de bits
en lugar de como oráculos o cajas negras.
El objetivo principal de esta lección es establecer una base
desde la cual podamos hacer eso.
Aquí tienes un resumen de la lección. Gran parte de ella la dedicaremos
al costo computacional,
es decir, qué tan difíciles son las distintas
tareas computacionales y cómo podemos medir esa dificultad.
En términos generales, esto se traduce en cuánto tiempo tenemos que esperar
para que los cálculos finalicen y, en última instancia, qué
problemas computacionales
podemos resolver y cuáles
están fuera de nuestro alcance.
Vamos a comenzar con
un par de ejemplos: la factorización entera y el cálculo del máximo común
divisor, o MCD para abreviar.
Son muy buenos ejemplos para ilustrar los
principios subyacentes, y además ambos son
muy relevantes para el algoritmo de Shor, que
veremos en la próxima lección,
así que aprovecharemos
al máximo estos ejemplos.
Luego hablaremos sobre la noción de costos computacionales de forma más general y cómo podemos medirlos.
Hay muchas formas distintas
de hacerlo, pero nos centraremos bastante
en cómo podemos hacerlo con modelos de circuit de computación,
específicamente circuitos booleanos
y quantum circuits.
El enfoque aquí estará en los algoritmos, en lugar del hardware de computadoras,
por ejemplo, y nos preocupará más
cómo escalan los costos de
ejecutar un algoritmo a medida que las instancias del problema en que se ejecuta crecen en tamaño, más que cuántos segundos,
minutos u horas requiere
un cálculo determinado.
La idea que motiva este punto de vista es que los algoritmos tienen
una importancia fundamental.
Todavía hoy seguimos
ejecutando algoritmos que fueron desarrollados hace
muchísimo tiempo y, de forma muy natural, seguirán siendo utilizados
con instancias de problemas cada vez más grandes
usando hardware más rápido y confiable a medida que la tecnología avanza.
Y la forma en que escalan nos dice mucho
sobre su utilidad actual y futura.
En la última sección de la lección, abordaremos una tarea de vital importancia: ejecutar computaciones clásicas
en computadoras cuánticas. La razón por la que esto es importante no es porque esperemos reemplazar a las computadoras clásicas
con computadoras cuánticas,
lo cual parece sumamente improbable que ocurra pronto, si es que ocurre alguna vez, sino porque abre
muchas posibilidades interesantes
para los algoritmos cuánticos.
En concreto, una vez que sabemos cómo ejecutar computaciones clásicas
en computadoras cuánticas, estas quedan disponibles para los algoritmos cuánticos
como subrutinas,
de modo que podemos aprovechar eficazmente todo lo que sabemos sobre los algoritmos clásicos en la búsqueda de ventajas computacionales cuánticas.
Las computadoras clásicas que tenemos hoy en día son verdaderas maravillas de la tecnología.
Son increíblemente rápidas, pero no tanto como para que ningún problema computacional
esté fuera de su alcance.
Algunos problemas computacionales
son tan intrínsecamente difíciles que, aunque sí existen
algoritmos para resolverlos, ninguna computadora en el planeta Tierra hoy en día
es lo suficientemente rápida como para ejecutar estos
algoritmos hasta completarlos en entradas de tamaño moderado dentro de la vida de un ser humano
ni siquiera dentro de
la vida útil de la Tierra misma.
Para explicarlo mejor, veamos el
problema de la factorización entera.
El enunciado del problema es muy simple. La entrada del problema es un entero N que es al menos dos, y la salida es la
factorización prima de N,
lo que significa una lista de los factores primos de N junto con las potencias a las que deben elevarse dichos números primos
para obtener N al
multiplicarlos todos.
Por supuesto, siempre podemos multiplicar los factores primos en cualquier orden, pero salvo por su ordenación,
las factorizaciones primas son siempre únicas para cada elección de N.
Ese hecho se llama el
teorema fundamental de la aritmética, y si te interesa
aprender más al respecto, lo puedes encontrar
al inicio de
muchos libros sobre teoría de números.
Como ejemplo muy sencillo, aquí tienes la factorización prima
del número 12.
Es dos elevado a la dos
por tres elevado a la uno.
No es de sorprender que una
computadora pueda decirte esto en un abrir y cerrar de ojos buscando
iterativamente los factores primos.
Aquí hay otro ejemplo. No voy a intentar leer este número.
Es alrededor de 3,4 cuatordecillones, y tengo que admitir que me parece curioso que exista ese nombre,
pero en fin, tiene 46 dígitos decimales y aquí puedes ver
su factorización en números primos.
Una computadora también puede decirte esto. Factoricé este número usando el método de factorización incluido en la biblioteca de matemáticas simbólicas
para Python,
y tardó unos pocos segundos, lo cual no es un tiempo especialmente largo, pero sí hubo un retardo perceptible.
Y desde luego, el método factor_N no encuentra esta factorización en primos buscando ingenuamente factores primos.
En realidad usa una combinación
de diferentes algoritmos, incluyendo uno llamado el
algoritmo de la criba coloreada, que es un algoritmo de factorización
más sofisticado que buscar iterativamente
factores primos de forma ingenua, y aunque eso pueda parecer
un número bastante grande,
como entrada a un problema computacional, en realidad no es tan grande.
Solo tiene 46 caracteres.
Aquí hay un ejemplo más. Es un número con 309 dígitos decimales.
Si lo escribimos en notación binaria, tiene 1.024 bits y por eso
se llama RSA1024.
La factorización en números primos de este número no se conoce actualmente.
Este número proviene del
desafío de factorización RSA, que fue organizado por RSA
Laboratories de 1991 a 2007.
Ofrecieron premios en efectivo
por las factorizaciones en primos de varios números de tamaño
creciente, incluyendo este, que valía 100.000 dólares,
pero ese premio nunca fue reclamado.
La seguridad del sistema
criptográfico de clave pública RSA se basa en la dificultad
de la factorización de enteros.
Si puedes factorizar, puedes
romper el sistema, y por eso el propósito del desafío era básicamente rastrear el
estado del arte en factorización.
En resumen,
factorizar este número está más allá de nuestras capacidades actuales.
Hasta donde sabemos, el
problema en sí es demasiado complejo para que las computadoras clásicas
lo resuelvan en la práctica.
El número del desafío RSA más grande que se ha factorizado hasta ahora, por cierto, tiene 250 dígitos decimales.
Quizás sea un poco difícil
de leer en la pantalla, pero aquí está la factorización
en primos de RSA250.
Se logró en 2020 usando un algoritmo conocido como la criba del cuerpo de números, y fue un esfuerzo colectivo que involucró decenas de miles
de computadoras alrededor del mundo.
Ahora, consideremos un problema
computacional diferente, que es el problema de calcular el máximo común
divisor, o MCD para abreviar,
de dos enteros no negativos.
Aquí está el enunciado del problema. La entrada consiste en dos
números esta vez, N y M,
y vamos a asumir que
no son ambos iguales a cero.
El objetivo es calcular el
MCD de estos dos números, que es el entero más grande D que divide exactamente tanto a N como a M,
y si piensas en las
factorizaciones en primos de N y M, lo que encontrarás es que el MCD es el producto de todos los números primos
que dividen tanto a N como a M elevados al mínimo de las potencias que aparecen en las dos
factorizaciones en primos.
Así que está relacionado con el problema
de la factorización de enteros, pero resulta ser mucho, mucho más fácil
de resolver para las computadoras. Podemos calcular MCDs de números con miles de dígitos
en un abrir y cerrar de ojos.
No tiene mucho sentido que intente mostrarte ejemplos en pantalla porque podríamos llenar la
pantalla entera de dígitos y aún seguiríamos describiendo
instancias fáciles de resolver de este problema.
Pero si te interesa, sigue el enlace en la descripción del video a la página del libro de texto de esta lección y encontrarás celdas de código
para los tipos de cálculos
de los que estoy hablando, incluyendo algunos que calculan
MCDs de números grandes, y puedes probarlos tú mismo.
La pregunta es: ¿por qué es posible calcular MCDs tan fácilmente?
Y la respuesta a esa pregunta es que tenemos algoritmos
eficientes para calcular MCDs.
Entre ellos está el algoritmo de Euclides, que fue descubierto hace más de 2.000 años, pero también hay otros
algoritmos eficientes de MCD.
Y por supuesto, aquí estamos hablando de algoritmos clásicos, lo que lleva a otra pregunta.
¿Podría existir un algoritmo
clásico eficiente para la factorización de enteros
que nos permitiera factorizar números como RSA1024
en un abrir y cerrar de ojos?
Y la respuesta es sí. Absolutamente podría existir un algoritmo clásico eficiente
para factorizar, y actualmente no conocemos ninguna forma
de descartar esa posibilidad. Todo lo que podemos decir es que
aún no hemos encontrado uno.
Para todos los algoritmos clásicos
de factorización que conocemos, seguimos esencialmente
buscando factores
y eso pone números como
RSA1024 fuera de nuestro alcance.
Los algoritmos eficientes de MCD,
por otro lado, simplemente no funcionan así.
No buscan el
máximo común divisor. Efectivamente lo construyen
con un procedimiento mecánico de un costo aproximadamente comparable
al de multiplicar esos mismos
dos números, y diré un poco más sobre esto más adelante en la lección.
Por supuesto, todo esto lleva
al algoritmo de Shor, que veremos en la próxima lección, que es un algoritmo cuántico eficiente
para calcular factorizaciones en números primos, pero aún tenemos algo de camino
por recorrer antes de llegar ahí.
A continuación vamos a hablar
de un marco matemático a través del cual podemos medir los costos computacionales
de diferentes algoritmos,
incluyendo algunos de los que ya hemos hablado.
Para ser claros, nos vamos a centrar muy concretamente en los circuits, que es solo una pequeña parte
de un tema mucho más amplio.
Empecemos con una visión muy general de una computación ordinaria
de la lección anterior, es decir, en particular que no estamos pensando
en problemas de consulta,
sino en
problemas donde la entrada se da explícitamente como una cadena binaria.
Como dije en la lección anterior, por supuesto podríamos usar
otros símbolos si quisiéramos, pero sigamos con lo simple y quedémonos con cadenas binarias
tanto para la entrada como para la salida.
La computación en sí podría modelarse o describirse de diversas maneras, como con el modelo de
máquina de Turing,
circuitos booleanos, quantum circuits, o programas escritos en
un lenguaje como Python o cualquier otro lenguaje de tu elección.
Como dije hace un momento, nos vamos a enfocar en
los circuits, tanto booleanos como cuánticos.
Primero, dediquemos un poco más de tiempo a hablar sobre la entrada y la salida, que asumimos son cadenas binarias.
Usando cadenas binarias, podemos codificar muchos tipos diferentes de
objetos matemáticos, como números, vectores,
matrices, grafos,
descripciones de moléculas, por ejemplo, así como listas de todos estos objetos y otros más.
Como ejemplo muy sencillo, si queremos codificar enteros no negativos
como cadenas binarias, podemos usar notación binaria.
En esta tabla verás los primeros 13
enteros no negativos junto con sus representaciones o codificaciones binarias.
En la tercera columna puedes ver la longitud de
cada una de estas codificaciones, que es simplemente el número total de bits que necesitas para la codificación,
y aquí hay una fórmula simple que te dice exactamente cuántos bits
se necesitan en general para cualquier entero no negativo N.
Nota en particular que
la longitud de la codificación es generalmente mucho menor
que el número en sí.
Es logarítmica respecto al número.
RSA1024, por ejemplo, tiene una codificación de longitud 1024, pero el número en sí
es por supuesto mucho más grande que eso.
Este esquema de codificación funciona
para enteros no negativos, pero si queremos manejar
enteros arbitrarios, incluidos los negativos, podemos
simplemente agregar un bit de signo.
También podemos permitir cualquier cantidad de ceros iniciales en estas codificaciones si queremos que
llenen un bloque de bits o un registro de tamaño fijo
siempre que sea suficientemente grande. A veces eso es muy conveniente.
Esta no es la única forma de codificar enteros como cadenas de bits.
Hay otras formas de hacerlo, pero esta es una forma bastante
estándar.
Para otros tipos de objetos que podrían formar las entradas o las salidas de los problemas computacionales
que nos interesan, podemos elaborar
otros esquemas de codificación.
Por ejemplo, piensa en cómo
podrías codificar un vector o un grafo como una cadena binaria, o piensa en cómo podrías codificar
dos cadenas binarias en
una sola cadena binaria usando solo el símbolo cero y uno, sin espacio ni ningún otro símbolo
para separar las dos cadenas. Desde luego hay formas de
hacer estas cosas, y de hecho tenemos mucha libertad
en cuanto a exactamente cómo lo hacemos.
A menudo no habrá una forma única estándar o universalmente aceptada para codificar lo que sea de lo que estemos hablando
como una cadena binaria,
pero eso está bien, podemos simplemente elegir una o inventar una nueva si lo preferimos.
Desde un punto de vista puramente formal, pensamos en las computaciones como transformaciones esencialmente mecánicas sobre cadenas de bits
y los detalles de los esquemas de codificación que usemos son ciertamente importantes en algún nivel.
Sin embargo, cuando estamos diseñando y
analizando algoritmos, normalmente no nos preocupamos demasiado por los detalles de
los esquemas de codificación.
Si le pides a dos personas diferentes que elaboren una forma de codificar, digamos, moléculas de un cierto
tipo como cadenas binarias,
podrías esperar que se les ocurran formas diferentes de hacerlo, pero si fueran personas razonables que supieran lo que hacen,
también podrías razonablemente esperar que sería un proceso computacional bastante
sencillo traducir de un esquema de codificación al otro y viceversa,
lo más probable es que requiera una computación muy
directa que sería bastante fácil comparada con la computación real
que nos interesa.
En resumen, los detalles sobre los esquemas de codificación que usamos suelen ser bastante secundarios y nuestro enfoque está en los
propios algoritmos.
Nada de esto va a ser un problema en esta lección, por cierto. Nos vamos a enfocar principalmente en problemas que involucran enteros, que asumiremos están codificados en binario,
pero es algo que conviene tener en cuenta.
En general, para cualquier tipo de problema del que estemos hablando, la longitud de la entrada se refiere
al número de bits que necesitamos para codificar la entrada,
y vemos la longitud de la entrada como el tamaño de la instancia del problema que estemos considerando.
Ahora, consideremos
la computación en sí, que está representada por el
rectángulo azul en esta figura.
La forma en que mediremos
el costo de esta computación es contando el número de operaciones elementales que requiere.
Intuitivamente, una operación elemental es aquella que involucra un número pequeño y fijo
de bits o qubits
que puede realizarse de forma rápida y sencilla, como calcular el AND de
dos bits, por ejemplo.
A nivel formal,
hay distintas formas de definir qué es una operación elemental, dependiendo del
modelo computacional que estemos usando.
Por ejemplo, una operación elemental podría ser un paso de una máquina de Turing si estuviéramos usando ese modelo.
Para los propósitos de esta lección, nos vamos a enfocar en los modelos de circuit, como ya he indicado, y específicamente en los
quantum circuits y los circuits booleanos.
Cuando trabajamos con circuits, es habitual que pensemos en cada gate como una operación elemental.
Hemos visto varios quantum gates diferentes hasta ahora en la serie,
incluyendo gates X, Y y Z, gates Hadamard, gates S y T,
gates NOT controlados, gates de intercambio, gates Toffoli y gates Fredkin.
También hablamos sobre query gates en el contexto del modelo de consulta, pero no vamos a trabajar con el modelo de consulta en esta lección, así que no nos preocuparemos por los
query gates por ahora.
También vimos que cualquier operación unitaria sobre cualquier número de qubits
puede verse como un gate si queremos hacerlo así.
Para medir el costo, sin embargo, eso no va a ser muy útil, así que lo que vamos a hacer es simplemente
elegir un conjunto de gates
y consideraremos ese conjunto como nuestro conjunto de operaciones elementales.
Primero, incluiremos los
gates unitarios de un solo qubit que ves aquí,
es decir, los gates X, Y y Z,
los gates Hadamard y los gates S y T, así como sus inversas
o transpuestas conjugadas.
En realidad no necesitamos todos estos gates. Con tener los gates Hadamard y T, podemos implementar el resto de ellos,
pero por conveniencia, vamos a incluirlos todos.
También incluiremos los gates NOT controlados, y estos serán los únicos
gates de múltiples qubits en nuestro conjunto.
Y finalmente incluiremos mediciones en la base estándar de un solo qubit, para poder obtener algo de información clásica
que salga de nuestros circuits.
Si nos enfocamos únicamente en los gates unitarios y olvidamos las
mediciones por un momento, obtenemos lo que se llama
un conjunto de gates universal.
Lo que eso significa es que
cualquier operación unitaria sobre cualquier número de qubits puede
implementarse de forma exacta
o arbitrariamente cercana
con un quantum circuit construido solo con estos gates.
En otras palabras, este es un
conjunto de gates suficientemente bueno como para construir cualquier operación unitaria
a partir de ellos.
No necesariamente de forma exacta, pero podemos obtener una aproximación
tan buena como queramos.
Eso puede requerir muchos gates, y en realidad no es tan difícil razonar que a veces debe requerir
muchos gates,
pero aun así, siempre es posible.
No es algo sencillo demostrar que este es un conjunto de gates universal, y no vamos a hablar de cómo
se hace eso en la serie,
pero es un hecho bastante conocido y en realidad hay diferentes
formas de demostrarlo.
También hay otros conjuntos de gates que a veces se usan
en lugar de este, como los gates Toffoli, los gates Hadamard y los gates S además de las mediciones,
pero esta es una elección bastante estándar.
Entonces, en resumen, estas son
las operaciones cuánticas que consideraremos elementales.
Para los circuits booleanos,
vamos a considerar estos cuatro gates como
operaciones elementales: gates AND, gates OR, gates NOT y FANOUT.
FANOUT, por cierto, no siempre
se cuenta como un gate, pero va a ser
importante para nosotros hacerlo así, como veremos más adelante en la lección.
Similar a lo que teníamos en
nuestro conjunto estándar de gates cuánticos, este conjunto es un poco redundante.
No necesitas tanto AND como OR. Puedes crear cualquiera de los dos usando el otro con tres gates NOT,
pero no hay ningún problema en incluir ambos y es simplemente conveniente.
Como ya sabrás, este es un conjunto de gates universal
para computaciones deterministas, lo que significa que cualquier función
de bits a bits
puede implementarse con un circuit booleano compuesto por gates de esta colección.
Una vez más, igual que
con los quantum circuits, esto no significa que toda función pueda implementarse de forma eficiente
mediante un circuit booleano,
y de hecho la mayoría de las funciones
solo pueden implementarse con circuits muy grandes
por la simple razón de que hay muchísimas funciones
y no todas pueden tener circuits pequeños. Simplemente no hay suficientes
circuits pequeños para todas.
La universalidad es más fácil
de demostrar en este caso que en el caso cuántico, resulta ser.
Así que si aún no sabes
cómo demostrarlo, piénsalo un poco y
a ver si puedes averiguarlo si te apetece.
Ahora que hemos decidido cuáles
gates vamos a permitir y que vamos a considerar
operaciones elementales, podemos pensar en cuántos de ellos
se necesitan para realizar
diversas computaciones.
Para eso, vamos a usar
esta definición para el tamaño de un circuit.
Esta definición funciona tanto para
circuits booleanos como cuánticos y es muy simple.
El tamaño de un circuit es el
número total de gates que tiene.
Por ejemplo, si volvemos
al mismo ejemplo que hemos visto varias veces, que es nuestro circuit booleano para calcular el OR exclusivo de dos bits,
vemos que tiene tamaño siete
porque hay siete gates: dos gates FANOUT, dos gates NOT,
dos gates AND y un gate OR. Si decidiéramos no contar
los gates FANOUT, que es común, tendría tamaño cinco,
pero vamos a contar los gates FANOUT, así que su tamaño es siete.
El tamaño de un circuit
corresponde al número de operaciones elementales
que necesitamos realizar.
Así que si ejecutáramos
esas operaciones de forma secuencial, el tamaño nos diría
cuánto tiempo tardaría,
por lo que puedes pensar en el tamaño de un circuit como representando el tiempo de ejecución secuencial.
Así es como vamos a
medir el costo computacional a efectos de esta lección.
Hay otra propiedad
de los circuits, sin embargo, que también puede verse como la cantidad de tiempo
necesaria para ejecutar un circuit, y es la profundidad del circuit.
Para ser precisos, la profundidad
es el número máximo de gates encontrados en cualquier camino desde un cable de entrada hasta un cable de salida,
lo que equivale al número de capas de gates que necesitamos
para crear el circuit, donde una capa se refiere a un conjunto de gates
que podrían ejecutarse simultáneamente porque no comparten
ningún cable.
Por ejemplo, nuestro circuit
de antes tiene profundidad cuatro, y podemos ver directamente en el diagrama que hay cuatro capas.
Los gates FANOUT pueden
ejecutarse simultáneamente, los gates NOT pueden
ejecutarse simultáneamente y los gates AND también pueden
ejecutarse simultáneamente.
Así que podemos pensar en la profundidad del circuit como una representación del tiempo de ejecución en paralelo.
La profundidad del circuit es sin duda una noción interesante e importante, y existen técnicas muy
sofisticadas que se pueden usar para reducir
la profundidad necesaria para algunos cálculos, a veces de forma bastante drástica, de hecho, pero es un tema avanzado
y no vamos a hablar mucho más sobre eso en esta serie.
Así que, una vez más, vamos a
medir el coste computacional en términos del tamaño del circuit, o en otras palabras,
el número de operaciones elementales necesarias para realizar un cálculo.
Al principio de la lección, hablamos sobre el problema de la factorización de enteros y vimos que el tiempo requerido por un algoritmo para resolver este problema
puede aumentar a medida que las entradas crecen en longitud, y esto es típicamente
el aspecto en el que nos centramos
cuando analizamos algoritmos.
Es decir, nos interesa cómo escalan los costes de ejecutar algoritmos a medida que las entradas se hacen cada vez más grandes.
Por supuesto, este tipo de escalado no es lo único que importa.
Por ejemplo, puede que simplemente nos interese encontrar los factores
de RSA1024 y ya está.
Así que en un caso así, estaríamos hablando de una
única instancia del problema donde nada está creciendo.
Pero cuando pensamos en algoritmos, la forma en que escalan sus costes
importa muchísimo y nos dice mucho
sobre los algoritmos.
Este punto de vista es
coherente con la idea de que los algoritmos son fundamentales, y como comenté antes,
con el paso del tiempo y el avance de la tecnología, se desplegarán contra
entradas cada vez más grandes.
Pero fíjate en que, aunque las entradas a los problemas computacionales
pueden crecer en tamaño, los circuits no crecen.
Cada circuit tiene un tamaño fijo.
Y por esa razón, si queremos describir un
algoritmo usando circuits, en realidad vamos a necesitar una familia de circuits para hacerlo,
y por familia de circuits nos referimos a una colección de circuits que se hace cada vez más grande para que podamos acomodar entradas
a medida que se hacen cada vez más grandes. Por ejemplo, consideremos un algoritmo determinista clásico
para el problema de factorización de enteros, quizás uno basado en división por prueba, pero los detalles no importan realmente
para este ejemplo.
En principio, podríamos
describir ese algoritmo usando una familia de circuits booleanos donde, si queremos factorizar un número
cuya representación binaria tiene N bits, tomamos el circuit CN de nuestra familia e ingresamos el número
que queremos factorizar
en los bits de entrada de ese circuit.
A veces podríamos elegir parametrizar estos
circuits de diferentes maneras, así que puede que no siempre sea el caso de que el N-ésimo circuit tenga N bits de entrada,
pero esa es una forma bastante típica de hacerlo. Naturalmente, a medida que las longitudes de entrada se hacen más largas, esperaríamos que los circuits
de esta familia se hagan más grandes
reflejando el hecho de que
factorizar números de cuatro bits es mucho más fácil que factorizar números de 1.024 bits, por ejemplo.
Y así, teniendo eso en mente, medimos el coste de ese
algoritmo mediante una función, que nos dice cuántas
operaciones elementales
necesitamos para cada posible longitud de entrada, y podemos hacer esto tanto para algoritmos clásicos como cuánticos.
Como ejemplo, consideremos el problema de la suma de enteros, que es sin duda mucho
más sencillo que la factorización
o incluso que calcular MCDs.
Para simplificar las cosas, supongamos que tanto N como
M son enteros no negativos y que están representados
por cadenas binarias de la misma longitud.
¿Cómo podríamos construir circuits booleanos que sumen estos dos números?
Bueno, empecemos con un algoritmo, el algoritmo estándar de suma, que es el análogo en base dos del método
que supongo que todos aprendimos para sumar números
con un lápiz y un papel, así que empezamos con los
bits menos significativos,
los sumamos, y eso nos da el bit menos
significativo del resultado junto con un bit de acarreo
que debemos tener en cuenta
cuando pasamos a la siguiente posición. Y seguimos avanzando por los bits, generando bits de salida
junto con bits de acarreo
hasta llegar al final.
Este método se puede
expresar de forma bastante directa en términos de circuits booleanos.
Una forma de pensarlo es comenzar con un pequeño circuit para sumar dos enteros de un solo bit.
Eso nos dará un número
entre cero y dos, donde el bit menos significativo es el XOR de los bits de entrada
y el bit más significativo, o el bit de acarreo si lo prefieres, es el AND de los dos bits de entrada.
A veces nos referimos a un circuit que realiza estas
dos operaciones juntas como un semisumador.
Eso funciona bien cuando
solo hay dos bits de entrada, pero si queremos sumar enteros con más de un bit cada uno,
vamos a necesitar manejar
los bits de acarreo de alguna manera.
Entonces lo que podemos hacer es encadenar
dos semisumadores y tomar el OR de los
bits de acarreo que producen para crear lo que se llama un sumador completo,
que es básicamente un circuit booleano para sumar tres números
de un solo bit.
Y una vez que tenemos un sumador completo, podemos sumar números
simplemente encadenándolos, avanzando desde el bit menos significativo
hasta el bit más significativo. Básicamente estamos implementando el algoritmo de suma estándar usando los sumadores completos para
manejar los bits de acarreo.
Entonces, ¿cuál es el coste de este cálculo?
Bueno, necesitamos siete gates elementales
para cada gate XOR, lo que significa 10 gates para un semisumador
y por lo tanto 21 gates para un sumador completo, que son dos semisumadores más un gate OR.
Entonces, al final del día, si nuestros números de entrada tienen ambos bits AND, necesitamos un medio sumador para
el bit menos significativo
y un sumador completo para cada uno de los demás bits, y el resultado final es 21 por N menos uno más 10, es decir, 21N menos 11 gates en total.
Si por alguna razón decidiéramos que no queremos
contar los gates FANOUT e incluimos los gates
XOR en nuestro conjunto de gates, necesitaríamos cinco N menos
tres gates en total.
Es útil saber exactamente cuántos gates u operaciones elementales se necesitan para realizar distintas computaciones,
como acabamos de ver con la suma de enteros.
Y, por supuesto, si realmente queremos implementar estas computaciones, necesitamos conocer estos detalles.
Pero si siempre entramos en tanto detalle, especialmente con
algoritmos más complicados, nos vamos a enterrar muy rápido en detalles
que en muchos casos tienen
importancia secundaria.
Una forma de simplificar las cosas que es muy común en el
análisis de algoritmos es usar la notación big-O,
que nos permite expresar
y comparar tasas de crecimiento de una manera bastante sencilla
y muy conveniente.
Y aquí puedes ver la definición que está detrás de esta notación.
Supongamos que tenemos
dos funciones G y H, que podemos pensar que toman valores enteros no negativos por simplicidad,
aunque eso no es realmente necesario. Por ejemplo, quizás G y H representen los costos de distintas computaciones.
Entonces decimos que G es big-O de H, lo cual se escribe tradicionalmente
con un signo igual como este.
Si G de N es a lo sumo alguna
constante positiva C por H de N, siempre que N sea suficientemente grande.
Esto se trata de lo que
ocurre cuando N crece.
Formalmente, lo que significa "suficientemente grande" es que existe alguna elección de N cero tal que la desigualdad es verdadera
siempre que N sea al menos N cero.
La clave aquí es que estos
números C y N cero son fijos.
Pueden ser cualquier número,
pero sean lo que sean, no pueden cambiar a medida que N crece.
Si nunca antes has visto este
tipo de definición, puede que te lleve un tiempo acostumbrarte, y puedes encontrar recursos
que expliquen este concepto
con mucho más detalle del
que puedo cubrir en esta lección.
Por lo general, lo que hacemos es elegir
la función H de forma simple para expresar algo sobre qué tan rápido crece la función G.
Por ejemplo, la función cuyo valor es 17 por N al cubo menos 257
por N al cuadrado más
65.537 es big-O de N al cubo, y puedes ajustar este
ejemplo a la definición
eligiendo C y N cero de forma apropiada.
Por ejemplo, si tomamos C igual a 18, tendremos que
la expresión es efectivamente a lo sumo 18 por N al cubo
siempre que N sea suficientemente grande.
Vinculando esta notación de nuevo con el
ejemplo de la suma de enteros, lo que podemos decir ahora es que existe una familia de circuits booleanos
para sumar enteros no negativos tal que el tamaño del circuit N, es decir, el que funciona
para entradas de longitud N,
es big-O de N. El tamaño real de CN
según nuestro análisis era 21 por N menos 11,
pero eso es big-O de N.
Ahora bien, no siempre es inteligente descartar detalles de esta manera, pero aquí tiene sentido
porque revela la naturaleza esencial del algoritmo de suma estándar, que es que su costo escala linealmente
en el tamaño de los números
que estamos sumando, y esta expresión no es sensible a algunos detalles de bajo nivel
de nuestro modelo,
como precisamente qué gates consideramos operaciones elementales.
Por ejemplo, si decidiéramos que los gates XOR deberían considerarse como
operaciones elementales, o que los gates FANOUT no deberían
contar como gates, o ambas cosas,
seguiría siendo cierto que la suma de enteros se puede computar con costo big-O de N.
Aquí hay otro ejemplo de
un problema computacional: la multiplicación de enteros.
De manera similar a la suma, podemos preguntarnos cuál es el costo
de esta computación.
Si consideramos el algoritmo de
multiplicación estándar, es decir, el análogo en base dos del método para multiplicar números
que se enseña en la escuela primaria,
que básicamente consiste en
desplazamientos y sumas cuando trabajamos con números en binario, encontramos que existen circuits booleanos de tamaño big-O de N al cuadrado
para multiplicar enteros de N bits.
No voy a detallar este caso. Por supuesto, los circuits son un
poco más complicados que los de la suma, pero si piensas en cómo funciona
el algoritmo de multiplicación
estándar, no debería sorprenderte.
En esencia, necesitamos hacer
aproximadamente N sumas, cada una con costo lineal, y así terminamos con
costo cuadrático en total.
Esto se puede generalizar. Si uno de los números tiene N bits y el otro tiene M bits, entonces necesitamos circuits de
tamaño big-O de N por M.
Aquí, por cierto, estamos usando una extensión de la notación big-O donde tenemos múltiples variables, pero se puede extender de esta manera,
y si te interesan
los detalles específicos, te remito al contenido del libro de texto
de la lección, que está enlazado en
la descripción del video.
En realidad es posible
multiplicar dos enteros de N bits de una forma
que es asintóticamente superior al algoritmo de multiplicación estándar.
En particular, el algoritmo de multiplicación de Schonhage-Strassen
multiplica dos enteros de N bits con un costo de big-O de
N por el logaritmo de N
por el logaritmo del logaritmo de N. Entonces, cuando N es muy grande, como
decenas de miles de bits,
esta es en realidad una forma
más eficiente de multiplicar, pero es compleja y la sobrecarga la hace poco práctica
para números más pequeños.
Así que agreguemos la multiplicación
a nuestra lista de ejemplos.
Y simplemente para mayor claridad, enumeremos el costo dado por el algoritmo de multiplicación estándar, que es big-O de N al cuadrado.
Así que, una vez más, nos centramos en la naturaleza esencial de este costo, que es que escala de forma cuadrática
o subcuadrática si usamos métodos asintóticamente superiores.
También podemos considerar el
problema de la división entera, que se enuncia con precisión en la pantalla.
Aquí estamos hablando de calcular un cociente y un resto, así que la respuesta consiste
en dos enteros, Q y R.
Una vez más, hay un algoritmo
estándar para la división y también tiene costo cuadrático y, al igual que la multiplicación,
existen de hecho algoritmos
asintóticamente superiores.
¿Cómo se comparan entonces los algoritmos de MCD?
Bueno, el algoritmo de Euclides resulta
tener costo cuadrático, y eso es lo que quise decir
antes en la lección cuando dije que podemos calcular MCDs
a más o menos el mismo costo que multiplicar dos números entre sí.
Una vez más, existen
algoritmos asintóticamente superiores en líneas similares a
la suma y la multiplicación,
aunque el costo es un poco
mayor en este caso, al menos hasta donde sabemos.
Voy a mencionar solo un ejemplo más de problema para añadir a esta lista, y ese es la exponenciación modular.
Aquí hay tres números de entrada,
K, M y N, y el objetivo es calcular
N elevado a la potencia K módulo M,
lo que significa el resto
después de dividir por M.
No es para nada obvio, pero podemos calcular la
exponenciación modular a costo de qubit, es decir, big-O de N al cubo
para enteros de N bits.
La forma de resolver esto no es calcular primero N elevado a la potencia K y luego calcular el resto.
Incluso escribir N elevado a la potencia K podría requerir exponencialmente muchos bits, así que ese enfoque no funcionará.
En cambio, podemos usar un algoritmo
llamado el algoritmo de potenciación, que también se llama exponenciación por cuadrados sucesivos, donde todo se hace módulo M
y usamos los bits de
K para elevar al cuadrado y multiplicar de forma iterativa de una manera
que lo hace funcionar todo.
Este es más
costoso que los demás, pero aún podemos realizar
la exponenciación modular con bastante rapidez en números
con muchos miles de bits.
¿Cómo se comparan entonces los costos de estas tareas con la factorización de enteros?
Si empezamos de forma simple y
pensamos en la división de prueba, donde primero comprobamos si dos es un factor del número de entrada
y luego comprobamos tres y así sucesivamente, terminaremos con un algoritmo bastante
costoso, big-O de N al cuadrado por
dos elevado a la potencia N sobre dos.
Cada división lleva tiempo cuadrático y, en el peor caso, tendremos que buscar factores primos hasta la raíz cuadrada del número de entrada,
y de ahí viene el N
sobre dos. Si en ese punto no hemos encontrado un
factor primo, podemos detenernos porque entonces
el número de entrada en sí debe ser primo.
Esto es extremadamente costoso porque N aparece como exponente en esta expresión, lo que significa que este
algoritmo tiene costo exponencial.
En cambio, todos los ejemplos que tenemos en este recuadro aquí tienen lo que llamamos costo polinómico, donde N se eleva a una potencia,
pero esa potencia es siempre un número fijo que no crece a medida que
crece la longitud de la entrada.
En estos casos, las potencias
son uno, dos y tres.
Volvré al costo polinómico frente al exponencial en un momento, pero primero, terminemos
con lo que sabemos sobre la factorización.
Antes mencioné
el método de la criba del cuerpo de números, que es el mejor
algoritmo de factorización que tenemos en términos de cómo escala su costo.
De hecho, el costo de este algoritmo no está rigurosamente probado porque está relacionado con algunas preguntas abiertas sobre teoría de números,
pero se conjetura que tiene
un costo que se parece a esto.
Esta vez el big-O está en el exponente, pero voy a pasar por alto ese
detalle.
El punto clave es que es significativamente mejor
que la división de prueba porque, aunque N sí
aparece en el exponente,
se eleva a la potencia 1/3 y eso se traduce en un costo mucho menor, y por eso este algoritmo
puede manejar números como RSA250, mientras que la división de prueba
definitivamente no puede.
Sigue siendo exponencial, sin embargo, en el sentido de que una potencia de N aparece en un exponente y, como resultado,
todavía no puede manejar
números como RSA1024.
Ahora déjame decir un poco más sobre el costo polinómico
frente al costo exponencial.
Decimos que un algoritmo
tiene costo polinómico si su costo es big-O de N elevado a la potencia B,
donde B puede ser cualquier número positivo, pero la clave es que B tiene que ser fijo, lo que significa que no cambia
a medida que la longitud de la entrada N crece.
Para los ejemplos que vimos hace un momento, es decir, suma de enteros, multiplicación, división, cálculo de MCDs
y exponenciación modular,
teníamos que B era
uno, dos o tres.
Así que todos estos son
algoritmos de costo polinómico.
Pero cuando decimos costo polinómico
en términos más generales, B podría ser cualquier número positivo.
Podría ser incluso un millón,
pero tiene que ser fijo.
Como una abstracción muy aproximada, los algoritmos con costo polinómico
se consideran típicamente como representantes de algoritmos eficientes.
Es definitivamente una simplificación excesiva, pero como guía aproximada, puedes pensar en un
algoritmo de costo polinómico
como uno que de alguna manera aprovecha
la estructura del problema para construir una solución, a diferencia de un
enfoque de fuerza bruta
o una búsqueda exhaustiva
sobre un espacio muy grande.
Por supuesto, un algoritmo cuyo costo escala como N elevado al millón
en entradas de longitud N
no sería razonablemente
considerado eficiente, y no esperaríamos poder
ejecutarlo en entradas grandes.
Pero aun así, incluso un algoritmo de N elevado al
millón tiene que estar haciendo algo inteligente que de alguna manera refleje la estructura
de cualquier problema que resuelva, para evitar el escalado exponencial en costo que estaría asociado con
una búsqueda exhaustiva sobre un dominio grande.
Y en la práctica, identificar un algoritmo de costo polinomial es realmente solo el primer
paso hacia la eficiencia.
Si un problema es importante
y alguien descubre el primer algoritmo de costo
polinomial para él, quizás con un exponente muy grande,
puedes estar bastante seguro de que los diseñadores de algoritmos
encontrarán mejoras que harán bajar ese exponente.
En esencia, puedes
pensar en la existencia de un algoritmo de costo
polinomial para un problema como una demostración de la viabilidad
de resolver ese problema
con entradas razonablemente grandes, pero aún podría haber mucho trabajo por hacer para alcanzar una verdadera eficiencia.
En la teoría de la complejidad, es habitual decir que el costo de un algoritmo
escala sub-exponencialmente si el costo es big-O de dos elevado a N
elevado a epsilon para todo número real positivo epsilon, y si no es sub-exponencial,
entonces es exponencial, o incluso podría ser super-exponencial como dos elevado a dos elevado a N,
lo que es doblemente exponencial,
pero mientras la salida
no sea super-exponencialmente larga, en realidad cualquier problema puede ser
calculado por un Boolean circuit
con costo exponencial, según resulta. Así que la distinción importante aquí es entre costo
polinomial y exponencial.
No conocemos ningún algoritmo clásico de costo sub-exponencial para
la factorización de enteros.
Por ejemplo, el costo del tamiz del cuerpo de números no es big-O de dos elevado a
N elevado a epsilon cuando epsilon es 1/3 o menos,
por lo que no satisface esta definición.
Sin duda es un algoritmo muy ingenioso, pero sigue siendo un tamiz y en efecto seguimos buscando
sobre un espacio muy grande para identificar los factores de un número dado.
Como veremos en la siguiente lección, de hecho existe un algoritmo cuántico de costo
polinomial para la factorización de enteros.
El algoritmo de Shor tiene costo polinomial y específicamente tiene costo en qubits, similar a la exponenciación modular.
Otra clase de problemas con la que
quizás estés familiarizado es la clase de problemas NP-completos.
No voy a explicar qué son los problemas NP-completos en esta lección, pero puedes buscarlos
si te interesa.
Se conjetura que
ninguno de estos problemas tiene costo sub-exponencial.
Eso es esencialmente una versión basada en circuit de lo que a veces se llama la
hipótesis del tiempo exponencial, pero hasta ahora nadie ha podido
demostrarla.
De hecho, ni siquiera podemos probar que no existan algoritmos de costo lineal para los problemas NP-completos.
Es simplemente muy difícil, al
menos hasta donde sabemos, descartar la posibilidad
de que en el futuro se descubra un algoritmo
increíblemente creativo para estos problemas.
Aquí hay una figura que
ilustra la relación entre el costo polinomial y el exponencial.
En el eje X tenemos la longitud de la entrada del problema que estamos considerando, y el eje Y representa el
costo de resolver ese problema
o puedes pensarlo
como el tiempo necesario para resolver el problema, si lo prefieres.
Un algoritmo de costo exponencial
podría escalar así.
Para entradas cortas, el costo puede no ser especialmente alto, como factorizar el
número 12, por ejemplo,
pero a medida que la longitud de la entrada se alarga, el costo eventualmente se va a disparar.
Un algoritmo de costo polinomial,
en cambio, podría tener un escalado que se vea así.
El costo seguirá aumentando en general a medida que las entradas se alarguen, e incluso podría costar más que el algoritmo de costo exponencial
para algunas entradas,
pero eventualmente va a ser
mucho menos costoso que el algoritmo de costo exponencial y no se dispara
de la misma manera extrema
que los algoritmos de costo exponencial.
Entonces, si imaginamos que
tenemos algún costo máximo que estamos dispuestos a pagar, o una cantidad máxima de tiempo que estamos dispuestos a esperar por una respuesta,
si prefieres pensar en términos de tiempo, entonces el algoritmo de costo exponencial solo funcionará para entradas
hasta cierta longitud,
mientras que, en general, el
algoritmo de costo polinomial nos permitirá resolver el
problema para entradas más grandes.
Y por eso, por ejemplo, podemos calcular fácilmente el MCD de números con muchos miles de
bits, pero en el peor caso,
no podemos factorizar números de ese tamaño.
En la última parte de la lección, centraremos nuestra atención en implementar cómputos clásicos
en computadoras cuánticas.
Más específicamente, veremos que cualquier cómputo que pueda realizar un Boolean circuit también puede realizarlo un quantum circuit
con aproximadamente el mismo costo. Además, esto puede hacerse
de manera limpia, lo cual es importante si queremos
ejecutar estos cómputos
como subrutinas dentro de
cómputos cuánticos más grandes, y explicaré qué quiero decir con "limpio" cuando avancemos más en la discusión.
Vamos a hacer uso de
Toffoli gates en este proceso.
Recuerda que los Toffoli gates son gates controlled-controlled-NOT, por lo que su acción sobre los estados de la base estándar
es la que ves aquí en la pantalla.
Observa que también podemos
pensar en los Toffoli gates como query gates
para la función AND.
Eso no quiere decir que sean query gates en sentido literal. Como mencioné al principio de la lección, no estamos trabajando dentro del
modelo de consulta en este punto,
sino que su acción sigue el mismo patrón que un query gate.
Podemos pensar en los valores binarios A y B como las entradas de la función AND y, al igual que un query gate,
estos valores se repiten
como parte de la salida y el valor de la función, es decir, el AND lógico de A y B
se aplica con XOR al qubit inferior. Ahora bien, no hemos incluido los gates Toffoli en nuestro conjunto de gates estándar.
Podríamos cambiar de opinión si quisiéramos, pero realmente no necesitamos
hacerlo porque, como alternativa, podemos implementar gates Toffoli
usando gates Hadamard,
gates T y T daga
y gates NOT controlados como ves aquí.
No es para nada obvio
que este circuit en particular implementa un gate Toffoli, pero lo hace, y puedes tomar mi palabra
o multiplicarlo todo tú mismo para practicar un poco más, o simplemente puedes pedirle a Qiskit o a Python
o a cualquier software que multiplique matrices que haga la multiplicación por ti.
Y puedes consultar el
contenido del libro de texto de la lección para ver esto hecho con Qiskit.
Ahora podemos pasar a simular gates booleanos con quantum circuits y todo lo que necesitaremos para
esto son gates NOT,
gates NOT controlados y gates Toffoli.
Estas operaciones son todas deterministas además de ser unitarias y a veces describimos
operaciones como estas como reversibles, y de hecho,
el estudio de la computación reversible es anterior a la computación cuántica y de ahí es de donde viene todo
este procedimiento.
Los gates booleanos de los que necesitamos
preocuparnos son los gates NOT, los gates Hadamard y los gates FANOUT,
Y lo que vamos a mostrar es que podemos implementar estos gates, o simularlos si
lo prefieres, usando gates NOT,
gates NOT controlados y gates Toffoli.
Para ser claros, lo que
queremos son quantum circuits que nos permitan calcular los valores de los gates booleanos que acabo de mencionar
cuando les damos qubits en
estados de base estándar como entrada.
Para entradas de estado cuántico arbitrarias, la acción estará determinada
por la linealidad como de costumbre.
No necesitamos hacer nada
especial con los gates NOT. Los gates NOT son gates NOT y se pueden implementar directamente.
Y los gates OR se pueden simular
usando gates Toffoli y NOT.
Los gates AND son fáciles, especialmente a la luz de lo que acabo de decir hace unos momentos sobre que los gates Toffoli son esencialmente
implementaciones de query gate
de la función AND.
Para ser precisos, lo que podemos hacer es introducir un nuevo qubit inicializado al estado cero
y hacer que ese qubit sea el
objetivo de nuestro gate Toffoli y que los dos qubits de entrada sean los controles.
Se les dan diferentes nombres
a los qubits adicionales como este, que a menudo se introducen
en los cálculos cuánticos, y yo los llamaré qubits de espacio de trabajo solo para elegir un nombre.
Nuestra suposición típica sobre los qubits de espacio de trabajo es que empiezan en el estado cero y a menudo podemos devolverlos
al estado cero
cuando terminamos con ellos, pero no siempre.
En el diagrama tenemos un ket cero dentro del rectángulo punteado para indicar que la
inicialización de este qubit
es parte del proceso, y si no tienes
un qubit nuevo como este, no vas a poder
hacer esta simulación.
El qubit de salida inferior
es el que nos importa porque ese es el resultado
de la operación AND y básicamente
ya terminamos con los otros dos
así que pueden quedarse dentro de la caja.
De hecho, incluso podrías imaginar que deshacerte de estos dos qubits es parte del trabajo de
simular este gate AND,
algo así como basura que
hay que limpiar.
Pero en fin, así es como
podemos simular un gate AND.
Ahora que sabemos cómo hacer gates AND, podemos hacer gates OR usando
una de las leyes de De Morgan.
Si pones gates NOT en las dos entradas y en la salida de un gate AND,
obtendrás un gate OR, así de simple.
Y el último es FANOUT, y para este solo
necesitamos un gate NOT controlado junto con un qubit de espacio de trabajo.
Concretamente, si
establecemos el qubit de espacio de trabajo como el objetivo, efectivamente solo copiamos cualquier estado de base estándar que entre,
lo que actúa como un gate FANOUT.
Así que ya tenemos todos nuestros gates.
Y ahora que tenemos todos nuestros gates, podemos pasar a los circuits.
Supongamos que tenemos
algún circuit booleano llamado C, y este puede ser cualquier
circuit booleano que elijas
siempre que esté compuesto de
gates AND, NOT y FANOUT.
Llamaremos T al número de gates en C y le daremos el nombre F a la función que C computa.
Así podemos pensar en F como la forma que ves aquí, donde N es el número de bits de entrada de C,
M es el número de bits de salida y sigma es el alfabeto binario.
Y lo que hacemos es simplemente ir uno por uno a través de los gates de C.
Dejamos los gates NOT tal como están y reemplazamos los demás con las simulaciones
que acabo de describir.
Entonces si C se ve así, lo que obtenemos es un circuit
R que se ve así.
En este diagrama, todos
los qubits de espacio de trabajo que necesitamos para las simulaciones han sido sacados de sus cajas y reunidos en la parte inferior.
Entonces K es el número total de
qubits de espacio de trabajo que necesitamos, que es uno por cada uno de los gates de C excepto los gates NOT.
Para la salida de R, tenemos los qubits que
corresponden a la salida de C, y aquí esos qubits
se muestran en la parte superior,
aunque en realidad no va a importar al final de todo esto
si están arriba o no.
Para ser precisos, suponiendo que hemos ejecutado R sobre un estado de base estándar correspondiente a una
cadena de N bits X arbitraria,
estos M qubits de salida estarán en el estado de base estándar
correspondiente a F de X.
También tenemos todos los qubits sobrantes de los gate AND y los gate OR.
Todavía necesitamos tenerlos en cuenta, y si los reunimos todos, estarán en algún estado de base estándar.
Cualquiera que sea ese estado de base estándar, tiene que ser alguna función de la cadena X, y vamos a darle
a esa función el nombre G.
Entonces G es una nueva función que está
determinada por los gate de C y que nos dice en qué estado
se encuentran estos qubits sobrantes
después de ejecutar R. G es la siguiente letra después de F, así que esa es una razón para
llamar G a esta función,
pero otra razón para llamarla G es porque G es la abreviatura de garbage (basura).
Todos estos son qubits basura, y en particular,
tenemos dos qubits basura por cada gate AND y por cada gate OR.
El número total de gate
que necesitamos es O grande de T.
Esto se debe a que para cada gate de C, necesitamos un número acotado de gate cuánticos.
El gate OR es el más costoso. Para ese, necesitamos tres gate NOT junto con un gate Toffoli,
y un gate Toffoli nos cuesta 15 gate de nuestro conjunto estándar de gate.
Así que eso es como máximo 18 gate
en R por cada gate de C.
Si quisieras optimizar esto, podrías hacerlo, pero para los fines de un
análisis asintótico aproximado, podemos simplemente decir que
R tiene O grande de T gate.
Así que hemos logrado
calcular la misma función F que el Boolean
circuit C calculaba,
y lo hemos hecho a un costo que es lineal en el tamaño de C.
Si lo único que nos importa es
calcular esta función F, entonces hemos terminado.
Pero desafortunadamente, sí tenemos
estos qubits basura, y estos qubits basura
en general van a arruinar
los patrones de interferencia que hacen funcionar los algoritmos cuánticos si intentamos usar este
circuit R como subrutina
dentro de un algoritmo cuántico más grande.
Pero en realidad sí podemos
deshacernos de esta basura, y la manera de hacerlo es aprovechar el hecho de que el circuit R puede invertirse,
o en otras palabras, podemos
ejecutarlo en sentido inverso.
Para ilustrar cómo funciona esto, imaginemos que primero ejecutamos R y luego ejecutamos R en sentido inverso,
lo cual podemos expresar como R daga.
Para ser claros al respecto, lo que significa es que aplicamos los gate
de R en orden inverso y tomamos los inversos
de cada uno de los gate.
Los gate NOT, los gate NOT controlados
y los gate Toffoli son en realidad sus propios inversos, así que si pensamos en
términos de estos gate,
entonces R daga es realmente solo R con los gate aplicados
en el orden inverso.
Pero en general, siempre podemos ejecutar cualquier circuit cuántico unitario en sentido inverso de la manera que acabo de describir,
lo que significa que aplicamos los gate
en orden inverso y reemplazamos cada uno de los
gate individuales por su inverso.
Si hiciéramos esto, encontraríamos que primero ejecutar R y luego ejecutar R en
sentido inverso no hace nada en absoluto.
Entonces si empezamos en un estado de base estándar como el que tenemos aquí, terminaríamos exactamente en el mismo estado de base estándar.
Por supuesto, hacer solo
eso no es muy útil, pero lo que podemos hacer es introducir un montón de qubits extra y, específicamente,
son M qubits, donde M es el número de bits de salida del circuit C.
Estos qubits adicionales pueden
estar en cualquier estado cuántico, pero para explicar cómo funciona esto, vamos a asumir que están en un estado de base estándar
correspondiente a alguna cadena Y. Entonces Y es una cadena de M bits, y lo que podemos hacer es realizar
un montón de gate NOT controlados
como los que ves aquí, que efectivamente aplican XOR a la cadena F de X
sobre la cadena Y almacenada
en estos M qubits inferiores.
Y así la salida de
todo el cómputo es como aparece en pantalla.
X e Y son cadenas binarias arbitrarias. X tiene M bits e Y tiene M bits, y también necesitamos K qubits de espacio de trabajo.
Cuando ejecutamos R, calculamos F de X y esa cadena se almacena
en los M qubits superiores, pero también tenemos un
montón de qubits basura,
así que aplicamos XOR a la salida F de
X sobre los M qubits inferiores y luego ejecutamos R en sentido inverso
para limpiar la basura.
Debo señalar que es importante que R sea determinista.
Si estos M qubits superiores pudieran estar en alguna superposición de
estados de base estándar, esto no funcionaría correctamente,
pero esto sí funciona cuando
R es determinista.
Entonces si comparamos el
circuit cuántico que acabamos de construir con el Boolean circuit C original, vemos que básicamente
funciona de la misma manera
que funciona un gate de consulta
para una función arbitraria.
Hay una diferencia aquí, que es que necesitamos
estos qubits de espacio de trabajo para que todo funcione, pero por lo demás hemos
construido efectivamente un gate de consulta
o un circuit de consulta para cualquier función que calcule C.
También logramos, por cierto, devolver los qubits de espacio de trabajo
a su estado inicial, por lo que en principio podrían reutilizarse
como qubits de espacio de trabajo para
cómputos posteriores.
Si queremos, podemos poner un recuadro alrededor de todo el quantum circuit y llamarlo Q, y la relación con
C se vuelve más clara.
El circuit Q será
más grande que C en general. Necesitamos unos cuantos quantum
gates en Q por cada gate de C,
y también necesitamos los controlled
NOT gates en el medio, pero el número sigue siendo
lineal en el tamaño de C.
También hay que señalar que este es un procedimiento completamente general que funciona para cualquier circuito booleano, y no hemos intentado optimizar Q en absoluto.
Para un circuit C específico, bien podría haber
formas de reducir el tamaño de Q, y eso incluye usar métodos
que reduzcan el número de
qubits de espacio de trabajo necesarios en caso de que eso sea algo
que queramos hacer, y ese es el procedimiento para ejecutar
cómputos clásicos
en una computadora cuántica.
Es bastante simple, pero es algo
importante que hay que poder hacer.
En particular, ahora que
sabemos cómo hacer esto, somos libres de usar cualquier cómputo clásico que queramos
dentro de cómputos cuánticos, siempre que sigamos esta forma en la que la entrada se hace eco y la salida se aplica con XOR
sobre un conjunto de qubits
igual que teníamos para los query gates.
El costo escala linealmente. Así que, por ejemplo, podemos
crear quantum circuits para problemas como la suma de enteros,
multiplicación, división, cálculo de MCD y exponenciación modular, y todo esto se puede hacer con el mismo costo asintótico
que para los circuitos booleanos.
Necesitamos qubits de espacio de trabajo para hacer esto, pero al menos están disponibles para reutilizarse cuando
terminemos con ellos.
Una última observación que vale la pena mencionar es que este método nos proporciona una forma de implementar query gates,
a lo que aludí en la lección anterior.
Es decir, si tenemos un algoritmo de consulta que toma alguna función F como entrada, y tenemos una forma de calcular
F con un circuito booleano,
entonces podemos seguir este procedimiento para construir un query gate para esa función y luego ejecutar nuestro algoritmo de consulta sobre él.
Si eso es algo útil o no depende del problema de consulta en sí y de lo que intentemos lograr, pero en esencia, esta
construcción nos proporciona
una forma de conectar el modelo de consulta con un modelo de cómputo más estándar.
En cierto sentido, así es como funciona el algoritmo de Shor para la factorización de enteros.
Vamos a construir
quantum circuits como este a partir de algunas de las operaciones aritméticas de las que hablamos antes en la lección.
Y al hacer eso,
le damos a los quantum circuits la capacidad de evaluar esas operaciones en superposiciones de estados clásicos.
Y como veremos, eso nos permite factorizar enteros de manera eficiente.
Eso es el final de esta lección, que se ha centrado principalmente en establecer una base
para los algoritmos cuánticos en un marco computacional estándar sin caja negra.
Hablamos del costo computacional principalmente a través del prisma de problemas relacionados con la teoría básica de números.
Discutimos el costo polinomial
versus exponencial para tareas computacionales, y vimos cómo los cómputos clásicos
pueden implementarse mediante quantum circuits de una manera limpia y sin basura que les permite usarse como subrutinas
dentro de cómputos cuánticos más grandes.
Espero que te unas a mí en la próxima lección, donde veremos cómo el algoritmo de Shor pone estas ideas en práctica, permitiéndonos factorizar
enteros con costo polinomial.
Hasta entonces, adiós.